Trascrizione: Paola Cutillo
Revisore: Helena Caruso
Questo è un periodo di cambiamento.
Lo si dice sempre
e probabilmente lo è sempre,
un periodo di cambiamento.
Ma i cambiamenti sociali,
i cambiamenti economici
che si stanno verificando in questi mesi
e in questi ultimi due anni
rendono questo periodo
molto difficilmente leggibile.
Avvengono cose di segno opposto
che impattano sulla vita delle persone
e sulla vita delle famiglie
in maniera forte e profonda.
È inutile negare che
il lungo periodo del lockdown,
il lungo periodo di paura,
il lungo periodo
di inconsapevolezza
di quello che stava succedendo
e di quello che poteva succedere
abbia inciso in maniera fortissima
su tutti quanti noi.
Abbiamo perso certezze.
Abbiamo perso
ogni forma di tranquillità
che ci consentiva di guardare
davanti a noi
con una serenità e un equilibrio
che abbiamo scoperto non avere più.
Questo dipende soprattutto
dalla riduzione dell’ottica di periodo.
Cioè, noi non possiamo più pensare
a lungo termine.
Lo abbiamo scoperto con dolore.
Lo abbiamo scoperto innanzitutto perdendo
una generazione intera,
e una generazione importante:
la generazione
che aveva in sé la memoria
di quello che era stato il dopoguerra.
Il dopoguerra
ha avuto
molte similitudini
col tempo attuale, se ci pensate.
Il dopoguerra era sulle macerie.
Il dopoguerra era l’entusiasmo,
la forza
quasi ottusa
della società di quel tempo
per riprendersi e per ricostruire.
Fu costruita l’Autostrada del Sole
in poco tempo.
Furono fatte grandi opere.
Questo Paese
voleva rinascere da se stesso.
Sono entusiasmi
che noi dobbiamo ritrovare.
Sono pensieri sociali,
pensieri collettivi
che dobbiamo cercare e trovare
in noi stessi.
Questo però nasce
ed è una necessità
che nasce e che si struttura
su una grande insicurezza.
Lo dicevamo prima: l’insicurezza
deriva dal fatto che
molte certezze
che noi avevamo
sono state minate.
Sono state minate
innanzitutto dal punto di vista,
ovviamente, della salute pubblica.
Indiscriminati tagli
sulla salute, sulla sanità
che erano stati fatti
per decenni
sono stati brutalmente messi all’incasso
dalla sera alla mattina.
Abbiamo scoperto
quanto contasse
l’attività ospedaliera,
quanto contasse il pronto soccorso,
quanto contasse l’assistenza domiciliare.
E sono state tutte scoperte
che hanno avuto un grave impatto
su noi stessi.
Questo si riverbera sugli elementi
fondamentali della nostra vita.
Uno degli elementi fondamentali
della nostra vita
è l’abitare.
Cioè, il luogo dove noi abitiamo,
il luogo dove noi viviamo,
il luogo dove noi passiamo il tempo
che non passiamo all’esterno.
Nel tempo e per molti decenni,
il processo era stato univoco.
Cioè, la vita era rivolta all’esterno,
il lavoro si era andato espandendo,
le donne avevano sempre più lavorato,
i giovani avevano sempre più lavorato.
Quindi c’era stata un’estroflessione
della vita familiare.
Ci si vedeva la sera a casa.
La pandemia ci ha messo di fronte
a un’altra necessità,
molto violenta,
molto brutale:
si deve poter convivere.
Si deve poter convivere per lungo tempo,
nel rispetto
degli spazi individuali
e nel rispetto degli spazi collettivi.
Nella coesistenza di entrambi.
Cioè, nello stesso luogo
si deve poter vivere insieme,
ma si deve anche poter stare da soli.
Chiaramente, questo provoca
un cambiamento fortissimo
nel mercato immobiliare, e va da sé.
Ma non soltanto nel mercato immobiliare,
anche nella scelta
degli spazi.
Anche in prospettiva.
Perché comprare casa
oggi significa anche decidere,
per una coppia,
se avere dei figli e quanti averne.
Perché non è facile poi cambiare,
non è facile poi andare altrove,
non è facile poi ridimensionarsi.
Non è facile nemmeno espandersi,
data la fluidità
del mercato del lavoro
che c’è attualmente.
Alcuni processi sono stati accelerati.
Io penso per esempio allo smart working.
Lo smart working era un’idea,
era un qualcosa di futurista
fino a tre anni fa.
Ci si pensava poco allo smart working.
La necessità dello smart working,
la possibilità dello smart working
ha portato
ad un velocissimo adattamento tecnologico
da parte, per esempio,
delle grandi aziende.
Da parte anche
della pubblica amministrazione.
E questo ha comportato che
lo smart working è diventato
di grande attualità.
Questo è un processo
che non si può interrompere.
Noi possiamo per decreto
rimandare la gente al lavoro,
ma abbiamo indicato una strada,
le aziende hanno scoperto una strada,
che economicamente
è eccezionalmente conveniente.
E quindi è molto difficile
che si torni indietro.
Soprattutto le persone e le famiglie
hanno scoperto quanto sia importante
e necessario
avere per ognuno dei componenti
della famiglia uno spazio,
dove poter essere connesso,
dove poter lavorare, studiare, insegnare,
senza avere sovrapposizioni
con gli altri elementi della famiglia.
Quindi,
se una casa piccolissima,
che serviva soltanto per dormire
o per vedersi la sera a cena e basta,
prima era un target
sufficiente, importante,
decisivo per una famiglia,
quindi si cercava la casa
più piccola ma in centro,
adesso la casa un po’ più grande,
anche in posizione semicentrale,
è molto più ambita.
La famiglia
vive con ritmi diversi.
Sugli stessi sentimenti,
sulle stesse emozioni,
sulle stesse vicinanze,
sulle stesse connessioni,
ma vive in luoghi diversi.
Ha bisogno di più spazio.
Io scrivo romanzi criminali e quindi
sono attento a certi fenomeni
come la violenza domestica.
La violenza domestica
ha avuto un’impennata.
Non eravamo abituati a convivere.
C’è stata un’enorme
recrudescenza di fenomeni come
la violenza sulle donne,
la violenza sull’infanzia.
Perfino sugli anziani.
La convivenza forzata in spazi ristretti
ha inciso moltissimo
sulla mente fragile
delle persone già inclini
alle debolezze e alle lesioni.
Questo è
un elemento da tenere socialmente
in rilevante attenzione.
Dobbiamo reimparare a stare insieme.
Lo spazio domestico, la casa,
assume un ruolo fondamentale in questo.
Fondamentale in questo.
Riguadagnare il piacere di stare in casa.
Con le nuove fruizioni delle storie,
con i grandi network, con i grandi schermi
che adesso sono a disposizione
a costi contenuti,
con le connessioni, soprattutto,
con gli investimenti che verranno fatti
in termini di innovazione tecnologica,
di banda larga,
fatalmente,
noi andremo a stare di più in casa.
Allora, creare,
procurarsi degli spazi sufficienti,
procurarsi degli spazi vivibili,
procurarsi degli spazi paradossalmente
in cui, stando insieme,
si può stare anche da soli...
Perché questo è fondamentale
per l’equilibrio personale.
Stare da soli è fondamentale.
Quindi, l’importanza della casa
è, se possibile, ancora cresciuta
rispetto al passato,
recente o remoto,
e soprattutto crescerà nel futuro,
con gli spazi riguadagnati nei borghi,
con gli spazi riguadagnati nelle province,
paradossalmente con gli spazi
riguadagnati nelle campagne,
ma anche con un’innovazione tecnologica
applicata con forza
e con immediatezza alle case.
Quindi, la nuova casa
deve essere smart,
deve essere sufficientemente grande
e non necessariamente
deve contemplare lo spostamento
da parte delle persone.
Diventa un mondo.
Diventa un pianeta,
diventa un piccolo pianeta.
Lo è sempre stata, forse,
ma adesso lo diventa
fatalmente e forzatamente di più.
In questa prospettiva, noi ci muoviamo
dal punto di vista sociale.